في تركيا وسوريا لتكات كل من تلك الدولتين
تستفيق على امل الا ويرافقه حزن وفي كل
يوم تمبش فيه فرق لانقاذ ناج بمعجزه يكون
الواقع امر فالزلزال غيب الكثيرين تحت تلك
الانقاد حيث ارتفعت حصيله وفيات الزلزال
المدمر في تركيا الى واحد واربعين
الفا وعشرين وفاه بحسب بيانات رئاسه اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه وافقى التقرير
فان سته الاف ومئتين واثني عشر هزه
ارتداديه وقعت عقب الزلزال المزدوج في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش وبينما يقوم نحو 20
الفا من فرق البحث بالعمل الى جانب
الاليات الثقيله اكدت دراسات تقيم الاضرار
التي لم تكتمل بعد ازاله 105,000 مبنى
لحقت بها اضرار جسيمه طبعا تسعى اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه لاقامه
الف بيت مسبق التجهيز خلال شهرين اما
حاليا اجمالي الخيام التي اقيمت في مناطق
الزلزال بلغت 250 الفا وستبلغ في وقت قريب
300 الف خيمه فالذين لا يملكون شيئا ضاقت
بهم السبل فوجدوا في تلك الخيام ملجا اما
الاخرون فينزحون لولايه اخرى حيث قرروا
العيش مع اقاربهم او استئجار منازل ريثما
يعيدون بناء بيوتهم لكنهم يواجهون مشكله
اخرى تتمثل بمحاولات البعض استغلال هذه
الكارثه ورفع ايجارات المساكن بشكل مبالغ
فيه وفي هذا السياق اكدت السلطات التركيه
انها ستتصدى لهذا الامر بحسم وعدى عن خطر
الهزات الارتداديه المخاوف قائمه خشيه من
زلزال مدمر اخر في السنوات المقبله حيث
وجه رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغل
عاجلا الى سكان المدينه للاسراع في اجراء
الكشف اللازم على قوه وقوه تحمل هذه
المباني التي انشات قبل عام 1999 للزلزل
في ائمه ان تهدم او يعيدون تعميرها وفق
القواعد التي تمكنها من مواجهه اي زلزال
محتمل في حين اعلنت ولايه اسطنبول نقلت 52
الف طالب من 93 مدرسه في انحاء المدينه
للدراسه في مدارس اخرى من اجل هدمها
واعاده بناءها او ترمي من بعضها
[موسيقى]